neben mir steht diese betroffene familie
die sechs stunden heute nacht im auto
ausharren musste sie dann in der nacht
ein uhr in die notunterkunft nach nach
sömmerda kam und dort dann bis heute da
waren musste neben mir steht andré er
ist sozusagen das oberhaupt der familie
andré erzähl doch mal wann seid ihr denn
gestern losgefahren was für eine
autofahrt ihr passwort in eurer absicht
daher sind sogar 16
drei von sechs geworden und nimmt als zu
beenden waren und wollte nimmt ihr
helfen und sagt es ist sagte da weg den
wir sonst noch mal gefahren weil da ist
frei da wurde geräumt
das nicht so und wie lange seid ihr denn
gefahren bis er dann gemerkt habt es
geht nicht weiter
drei kilometer vier kilometer dann und
dann war stopp und was habt ihr dann
gemacht hatte dann versucht das auto
frei zu legen
wir haben versucht mit dem schlitten vom
beginnt mit plastischen und kind frei zu
schaufeln
und immer wird doch so zurückgefahren
und wird ein bisschen frei geschaufelt
und immer wieder versucht irgendwo raus
zu kommen
keine chance ging nicht sie wollen ihr
habt auch dann versucht natürlich
telefonisch hilfe zu holen wie oft habt
ja is denn probiert und wo habt ihr es
probieren anrufe und die leitstelle
versucht anzurufen das ja kein notfall
dann keine hilfe
dann haben wir privatleute versucht
anzurufen freunde bekannte wir konnten
alle nicht weg und dann haben wir dann
schlussendlich die polizei gerufen und
die polizei dank der polizei und dann
nochmal erneut die feuerwehr haben wir
dann auch der lage heraus als das auto
steht zwar immer noch da und die
unterkunft die nacht war zwar glücklich
aber jetzt eigentlich immer durchlaufen
mussten wie viele stunden war hier am
auto gefangen
o
56 stunden ihr habt ihr euch denn da die
zeit vertrieben er musste durch es war
ja auch kalt
eine kleine so versucht irgendwo zu
beschäftigen und mitspielen so so inhalt
und ich habe einen salto versucht alte
freizukriegen in der zeit mit dem tal 31
aufwärmen
und ja bis zu einem halben liter motor
zu erhitzen und warum werden gesagt an
de zu einem teil daran dass beweist
hatten die polizei gerufen
die euch dann letztendlich auch gerettet
hat wir sind bild und wir liefern dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren